[Music]
thank you
hey very good morning to you the top
stories from Sky News live in the city
of London boroughs are urged to act fast
as hundreds of mortgage deals are taken
off the market
members of the crisis hit CBI begin
voting on its future
flying off the shelves Harry Potter
publisher Bloomsbury posts record sales
and I'll be speaking to its chief
executive
plus the rise of Nvidia how the AI chip
maker joined the tech Elite with a
valuation of one trillion dogs
[Music]
a very good morning to you thanks so
much for joining us here on Ian King
live with me Wilfred Frost filling in
for Ian this week an hour of course of
business and economic news from the
heart of the city of London now a group
of tech experts warned yesterday that
artificial intelligence could Wipe Out
the human race but AI is Big Business of
course and yesterday the tech giant
Nvidia which supplies artificial
intelligence hardware and software
joined the elite club of the likes of
Apple Amazon alphabet and Microsoft when
it was albeit briefly valued at more
than a trillion dollars Nvidia makes
chips that are key to AI Technologies
such as the chat gbt generative AI
chatbot and on Monday it launched a new
range of products for AI including a
supercomputer platform well joining me
to discuss uh this is Sophie Lund Yates
lead Equity Alice at Hargreaves
Lansdowne Sophie thanks so much for for
joining me I mean a remarkable feat of
course from AI there's four or five
companies still over a trillion it's the
eighth across it of course some of them
have fallen back since it puts uh it
puts uh UK Innovation a little bit a bit
to shame that they've got that scale of
success but while we all know that they
you know linked to AI they're linked to
uh to to to computer games and making
chips for all of that to just break down
for those of us that aren't experts on
broadly what Nvidia does
hi good morning great to be back so
you're absolutely right Nvidia is very
well known for its gaming chip so
essentially it's it produces and is well
known for producing the very clever very
high memory chips that go in graphic
heavy video games and that's where
Nvidia um has really kind of made waves
um from from when it started the
difference is that very high memory
capacity is exactly what AI needs so
when you're training AI algorithms
um you need this particular chip that
nvidium makes and that's where this huge
Market excitement has come from and just
to put that into a little bit of
perspective you know you mentioned chats
GPT there or training chat GPT used 10
000 of nvidia's chips so that's the kind
of scale that we're looking at here and
and again in terms of this latest paper
I mean it was a huge company it was uh
doing incredible things in the gaming
space that that made it really not just
the lead player but the only player when
it came to uh to to manufacturers
wanting to to power their gaming
consoles and and the PC the gaming part
of PCS when did this pivot come towards
powering AI too and how critical is it
to its valuation is it 50 50 Ai and
gaming if we're being crude or what's
the balance
yeah certainly so really and Nvidia has
been kind of growing its AI area of the
business for quite a few years now it's
been kind of rumbling away in the
background
um but it's only been in recent weeks
that we have seen this absolute
explosion
um in the focus onto Ai and there's a
couple of reasons for that um in its
latest earnings so it's results that it
released to the market
um you know a few weeks ago it mentioned
huge increases in Revenue that massively
um surpassed unless the expectations
because of the AI surge you know we've
only seen the AI Trend really go quite
viral and kind of into the more public
sphere
um more recently so that's what's
happened and then also
um in recent days it's released
um the announcement saying but it's got
this new bigger and better AI chip and
that's where the market last week got
very very excited and in terms of how
important is this for valuation well
actually the level of excitement that
we're seeing or Nvidia is purely coming
from AI at the moment this very you know
I describe it as a frothy evaluation
that's very much coming from AI
excitement
um and I think the fundamentals of the
core business so that gaming and that
you were talking about there I think
that's being left behind a little bit at
the moment which does increase the the
risks of ups and downs well and let's
touch on that on the share price
performance because you know like all of
the big tech stocks it it initially
peaked in in 2021 pulled back
significantly uh through no fault of its
own really as in the entire NASDAQ did
and then this year it has ramped
aggressively just just talk us through
uh the share price performance over the
last few months and and and then link it
to where its valuation is now in terms
of as you say whether there's a risk
that this is getting into sort of
bubble-like territory
yes absolutely so the the performance at
Nvidia has been really um very
impressive as you say there's been
broader excitement around around Tech
and it's very much been swept up in that
um one of the reasons that we're seeing
really quite substantial increases with
Nvidia is it's not just focused on on
Tech per se it's an important supplier
to the tech space now that is a higher
margin arguably more attractive place to
be than say somebody that is producing
um Tech Hardware
um so it's operating margins are very
attractive compared to to some others in
in the space so that's a big a big
leader there
um but as we all know you know price is
what you pay and value is what you get
that that old saying and the valuation
now is very toppy
um now the excitement to a large degree
I think it is warranted there is a lot
to be excited about wearing video is
concerned and but the degree of this
valuation growth and so what the what
the market is prepared to pay per one
dollar of future earnings is very high
so there's certainly a lot to live up to
I'm not saying it can't do it but the
bar has been set very very high
yeah amazing uh rebound more than halved
from from late 2021 to early 2023 and
then uh comfortably more than doubled up
about 160 percent from from trough to
Peak over the course just of this year
the last few months so just expand on
that quickly as we round things off
Sophie in terms of whether there are
lessons to draw for the broader U.S
market at the moment which is you know
put to put the rest of the world to
shame as is so often the case uh and
including just over the last month the
footsie's down about four or five
percent uh the the US market the NASDAQ
in particular is higher
um to what extent is it focused just on
just a couple of stocks like and video
yep so there's a huge um focus on on
Tech in the US is certainly a
contributing factor there's no getting
away from it
um whereas the UK we know the UK Market
which are here for the ftse 100 is very
much weighted towards very beaten up
sectors that includes things like
Financial so your big Banks and your
insurance companies um which are exactly
the kind of stocks that struggle to to
find their their jumping off point
they're lifting off points um when
economic conditions are wobbly and to
say the least so there's that kind of
dynamic going on as well and then of
course there is the wider conversation
about the The Wider competitiveness of
London compared to the likes of New York
in terms of
um in terms of how comfortable the lse
is for high growth companies and keeping
hold of homegrown Talent as well you
know we have a great
um Tech Minds in this country but a lot
of them are finding themselves going
overseas and so there is certainly a
broader conversation to be had about how
we can better keep hold of that Talent
Sophie thanks so much for joining us
thank you
right uh time for some other business
headlines now wh Smith's has forecast a
higher full year profit has it been on
strong travel demands during the summer
the retailer said it's seen robust
trading across its Global Travel
business the company reported that it's
total group revenue for the 13-week
period ending the 27th of May was up 23
year over year
the UK's First post-brexit Trade deals
have come into Force Under the new
agreement tariffs on all UK Goods
exports to Australia and New Zealand
will be removed with red tape slashed
for digital trade and work visas the
first shipment of British goods will
include signed Beno comics
longer lorries will be allowed on roads
in the UK from today the maximum length
has been extended by over two meters
meaning they'll have a larger tail swing
and bigger blind spots it's aimed at
moving more Goods in fewer trips but
safety campaigners say it's a risk to
pedestrians and cyclists
well 10 of all residential and buy to
let mortgage deals have been taken off
the market over the last week house
buyers have been urged to act quickly
before mortgage deals are replaced with
higher rates or removed from the market
entirely according to money facts since
core inflation figures came out higher
than expected last week lenders have
pulled at least 390 residential deals
Rachel springle from money facts joins
me now Rachel excuse me thanks so much
for uh for for joining me um let's just
touch quickly more broadly around the
last week on on the sort of level of the
best rates that have been available over
the course of this calendar year and and
whether or not those best rates are the
ones that have disappearedly
indeed yes so our research has actually
revealed that the volatility in the
market has returned surrounding the
future interest rate expectations what's
actually happened within the residential
and by to let Market is that lenders are
perhaps temporarily withdrawing some of
their mortgage ranges and we're looking
at fixed primarily as in fixed rate
mortgages obviously with those they are
ideal for borrowers who want that bit of
Peace of Mind with locking in for say
two or five years but in terms of rates
as you rightly say we are looking at
volatility across the rates as a whole
so mortgage interest rates on the fixed
rates are rising and if again we look
back at perhaps say a year or so ago
we're looking at around an average of
three percent on your fixed mortgage
you're actually now looking over five
percent and it's nearing six percent we
haven't seen averages of six percent
since the volatility surrounding the
fiscal announcement so we're keeping a
very close eye on what's going on on the
market and again a lot of these lenders
May well be temporarily withdrawing
their ranges but we are urging Boris to
obviously have a look at what deal you
have right now see with your broker if
you can refinance because a lot of
lenders are pulling fixed rate deals
so let's just focus on these fixed rate
deals because it's easier to compare
obviously and it's a good indicator of
roughly where the market's at as you
said they spiked temporarily around the
mini budget last uh last Autumn that
they did settle back down for quite a
decent period of time to to some
availability of 3.99 for example as you
said ticking up of of late but but is it
fair to say for a different reason than
was the case back in September not
necessarily a good reason you know
inflation is is sticking around but but
it's not that momentary Spike because of
a sort of disastrous economic policy
exactly that we're not seeing the kind
of volumes that we saw back then we are
seeing more of a temporary perhaps
knee-jerk reaction to the Future
interest rate expectations so the way
that lenders obviously need to
appreciate their own business model is
to price accordingly so when they have
low fixed rates and they're tying their
borrowers in for two or five years they
have to maintain that fixed rate so what
lenders are doing at the moment they're
reassessing their propositions and
they're trying obviously not to be too
low not too high so it has resulted in a
few fixed rate mortgages actually being
pulled off the market while they
reassess their propositions I mean we've
been debating a lot whether it's petrol
prices food prices you know the extent
to which the the companies are price
gouging and making excessive profit
what's the view on the banks here
because it's interesting that the bank
of England base rate you know and then
again if you look out further down the
yield curve the the 10-year yield for
example we're talking of rates in and
around four percent
so if they're offering these fixed
mortgages at five or even six percent is
that an excessive margin that they're
trying to Arbitrage but before that what
is the long-term Norm for a bank on on
those sorts of margins
yeah I mean that's a really interesting
question but again every lender will
have their own business model and what
we've actually seen the last few weeks
is a lot of the deals to be pulled were
from building societies now mutuals can
work a lot quicker than banks in terms
of pulling and launching new ranges but
the way that Banks work is they look
primarily across pricing and that's
something that we are noticing at the
moment so what I would say is have a
look at the big Banks and the biggest
lenders in terms of what they're
repricing their mortgage is at so they
could be having to make a lot of hikes
in the next few weeks and days months to
kind of compensate for these future
expectations of rate Rises indeed with
base rate expected to go to 5.5 they
need to have a rethink about what
they're pricing right now
and then just finally I mean lots of
debates you know when you when it comes
to the economy more broadly but
specifically house prices as well we saw
them decline for four or five months in
a row then just fractionally tick up
more recently raise the question from
some oh is the worst of the house price
decline behind us but I guess are we
getting a glimpse over this last week
that a it takes a long time for interest
rate Rises to filter through to the
market and B that there's no Prospect of
interest rates falling anytime soon
absolutely so a lot of these interest
rate changes are not an overnight
sensation they do take a few weeks if
not months to filter through indeed if
you're on a revert rate you might not
immediately see a change but over the
next three to six months you may well
now what we would say in terms of the
mortgage pricing and housing Supply is
that demand is high and Supply is short
and if you have that within your housing
sector regardless you're going to have
the key issues of affordability and a
cost of living crisis on top of that
with affordability for buying a house is
a not very great concoction so the fact
that a lot of the fixed rate mortgages
are being pulled at the moment and
repriced it's just going to cause more
issues for borrowers looking to afford a
new deal or indeed get on the housing
ladder Rachel springham thanks so much
for joining us
where we talked a lot on this program
about the lure of listing in the United
States versus uh here in London and arm
the cambridge-based microchip designer
was of course the latest high profile
company to snub London and list on the
New York Stock Exchange instead but can
European companies have the best of both
worlds
OTC is a us-based trading platform that
acts as a global gateway to U.S public
markets for international issuers
joining me now from New York is Jason
Paltrow it's the Executive Vice
President of corporate services from OTC
markets group but Jason very good
morning to you thanks for for getting up
uh uh early for us in New York so just
break down what exactly you're doing
that's suggesting things are different
because clearly for a long time uh
companies big earns more can have dual
listings in multiple places and I think
what we've been debating of late with
arm as a high profile examples is really
where the primary listing goes uh not
just the soul listing
right and so what we've done here at OTC
markets is provide companies from around
the world kind of that Best of Both
Worlds uh we believe that companies
should be national champions in their
home markets uh we provide the largest
stock market in the U.S for
international companies that are seeking
that Best of Both Worlds they want
access to U.S investment uh whether
that's the retail investor or the high
net worth investor uh the third fourth
tier institutional or even the largest
institutional investors but they don't
want to do it with that added cost and
complexity of having to be a
sarbanes-oxley compliant SEC registered
issuer the SEC recognized long ago that
the disclosure regimes in London and
Switzerland and Germany and the rest of
the world were actually pretty good and
so gave companies the ability to have a
secondary Market in the U.S uh using a
foreign private issuer exemption that
basically said so long as they were
current in their home market and making
that information available
publicly through our markets these
companies these could have a secondary
Market with a stock ticker that's quoted
in dollars where the stock trades in US
Dollars during U.S market hours while
still being primarily listed on their
home market and we think this provides
companies really rather than the you you
know the London or New York it can be a
London and New York you can have access
to all of the same investors you can
work out the same issues that we're
hearing
um whether it's valuation or access to
investment capital and you can do that
again without the added kind of cost and
complexity of having to be a U.S
reporting company
so clearly one of the perhaps the
biggest attraction for companies based
abroad to the US based here for for
wanting access to the US market is a
premium valuation multiple and and uh
you know earning a higher share price
per unit of earnings or per unit of
Revenue does that get offset a little
bit by this process because will the
secondary listing that you'd be talking
about also then traded a slight discount
to what perhaps it would have been if it
was a primary listing
I don't think so because you're getting
access to U.S investors that are valuing
those companies based on U.S views and
multiples so for instance today we had
an lse company join us uh in the lithium
space right they're an lse company but
they realize that the valuations that
investors in the U.S are giving to
things like lithium or other clean tech
Metals helps them kind of bridge that
Gap and so by adding that U.S investor
interest you do see that Gap kind of
narrow and companies are able to solve
for that again it's a trade-off because
you're doing it without having to be a
sarbanes-oxley reporting company which
for most companies is really onerous
really onerous incredibly risky and
Incredibly costly
no I was I guess I was asking uh it
might be a premium to what their soul
London listing was but would it be a
discount to have they done a sole New
York listing but but we're getting in in
the weeds a little bit there
um I wanted to move on to to touch on
some of the reforms that you've seen
particularly in in the UK proposed
whether it's from the FCA or from the
government with the the so-called
Edinburgh reforms did you think they are
getting at the right issues that would
solve the the issue that that currently
exists for British companies
I think it comes with significant risk
you know London has always been the gold
standard for disclosure and transparency
and when you look at
um you know the the exemption that we
use it really looks at London and says
your disclosure standard is excellent
and so we're going to allow you to
passport that in order to be traded here
in the U.S
um to start fiddling with shareholder
protections I think is a risky
proposition and I don't know if that's
really going to get you anywhere I don't
know that if you looked at the U.S and
said oh that's the Panacea and you guys
you know it's so much easier to list in
the US and you don't have all these
regulations I'm not sure that's the
right argument to make I think
um you have to really be careful when
you start looking at taking away kind of
what the core value proposition of
London is which is really strong
investor protection
um again what I would call the gold
standard and I think it's important to
remember that and that's part of why the
London Market is is so good if you look
at who your core investors are whether
that's Pension funds
um insurance companies they need those
types of protection in order to make
good investment decisions and I would be
cautious of watering them down too much
I guess my final question is just in
terms of the Outlook clearly the big
factor behind why U.S markets have
outperformed Europe has been the genuine
fundamental performance of the
underlying economies and and companies
and and that has a sort of
self-fulfilling aspect to it over time
when you are marketing a British based
company via a new dual listing to the US
to what extent does it really change the
decision-making of the investor did they
not still look at it as oh great we can
buy the Dollar Listing but it's still a
UK based tech company and that's not as
attractive as the U.S tech industry
which you know we just discussed in
video for example just has better
prospects
well I think one needs to remember that
for a lot of U.S investors they don't
have access to UK companies and so if
nothing more than just getting the
visibility and putting themselves on the
same level as their U.S peers that
becomes incredibly important uh the U.S
has one of the largest pools of
self-directed investment in the world
um which is what these companies are
trying to access and for many of those
self-direct investors that are looking
at whether it's U.S tech biotech fintech
mining resource they don't have access
to go directly into London Germany
Switzerland to be able to buy those
Securities so being able to open that up
to U.S investors actually gives them
opportunities they didn't have before
and allows these companies to kind of
show themselves off and again get the
best of both worlds they can stay
national champions while accessing those
investors that otherwise wouldn't have
been able to buy into them and I think
that becomes incredibly helpful both as
it brings liquidity back into London
which is an important issue as U.S
investors are now buying those
Securities but again it increases the
value valuation of the company and gives
it access to that broader investment
pool again all of this without the kind
of added cost and complexity and risk
associated with becoming a full SEC
reporting servants optionally compliant
company
Jason thanks so much for joining us
really interesting
thank you thank you
right so to come here on Ian King life
uh we'll take a look at how Global
markets uh are faring this morning uh
and also look ahead to a key vote for
the CBI
[Music]
and tell me how you survive a crisis
you
not necessarily for the specific because
some crises come out of a blue sky but
you'll make yourself as resilient as
possible and that's true if you're an
individual or an organization or
government itself and you get into real
trouble when you haven't made sensible
precautions I think of a crisis as being
poised
between on the one hand emergencies that
we've practiced prepared for the
Emergency Services and on the other hand
disaster
and what makes the difference what tips
it over is preparation think about some
of the things which might happen
probably they weren't but if they did
it would be very serious the most
obvious is is your apartment or your
house if it catches fire
take out insurance
do you have a spare set of keys
or would you discover that you're locked
out
your best best apparel to appear on Sky
News is inside the taxis outside time is
ticking by
don't get yourself into that sort of
crisis situation and those are trivial
examples but it's the little things
attention to detail and I use the word
anticipation because what it it means is
you conjure up a real picture in your
mind
feeling of what it would be like if it
happened they come in two forms there's
the Sudden Impact crisis that you can't
really foresee when it will happen and
you just have to make do with the best
you can if you prepared but the really
dangerous ones are the Slow Burn crises
year on year the situation worsens but
nobody quite likes to tackle it or it's
thought to be too expensive or
governments just simply prefer to ignore
it
[Music]
welcome back let's get a look in on What
markets have been doing overnight
particularly in Asia where we saw some
significant selling Australia and Japan
both down more than one percent Hong
Kong down uh two percent uh and uh worth
noting now that Hong Kong is in Bear
Market territory down 20 from its uh
Peak and for the month of May Hong Kong
down nine percent uh or nearly 10 with
today's uh decline
um in comparison by the way career in
the month of May up three percent uh
because of its links to the supply chain
of AI Europe today is down about half a
percentage down more at the open in fact
in fact Spain's now even gaining and uh
we're down more like a third of a
percent for most of Europe France for
example down 0.4 percent uh had been
down uh a percent or so at the open so
slightly improving sentiment through the
morning uh for European trade the ftse
something similar as well uh it is uh
down but uh down less than it was at the
open down just two tenths of a percent
at the moment in terms of sectors
utilities telcos are the best performer
Autos consumer goods are the worst
performers by the way for the month of
May the footsies looking at a decline of
about four percent its exposure to China
uh a factor in why you're seeing
declines for the month of May quite
serious to clients as well four percent
for a single month right let's have a
look now at Forex you can see there the
pound is down about half a percent 124
against the dollar the Euro against the
dollar down a bit more than that some
softer than expected better than
expected you could say inflation data
out of France continuing a recent trend
of Continental European uh inflation
just coming in a little bit lighter than
expected and that's uh Weighing on the
Euro as it of course also impacts yields
in Europe but declining uh declining
there and finally let's have a look at
oil prices uh down again today half a
percent for Brent and again just to cap
the month of May uh once it's in the
books at the end of the day down about
eight or nine percent It's been a or a
month for Commodities in general
and let's discuss all of this uh Richard
Hunter the head of markets at
interactive investor joins me very good
to you Richard thanks uh thanks for
joining us let's touch uh Touch first on
this performance both today and over the
last month or so uh in Asian markets
particularly the the china-related
markets clearly that's happening because
the hopes of this uh this post-covered
reopening economic bounce are
diminishing has the pullback gone too
far if we talk about Hong Kong stocks
down 20 from their recent Peak
yeah it's a tricky one at the moment
because
um what we had seen in terms of pricing
was that uh it was very much expected
there'd be a very strong rebound after
China decided to abandon its Zero
Tolerance covid-19 policy unfortunately
what subsequently happened after
something of a bounce is that um it
seems to have stalled somewhat now if
you look at the projected GDP growth
which is in itself a slightly lower
figure than Market participants had been
hoping that's even
um even so that's that's projected to
come in at about five percent but the
latest Brian the ointment was overnight
some Chinese manufacturing data which
suggested contractionary territory and
it now becomes apparent that the Chinese
authorities may have to intervene again
uh in order to give the uh rebound
something of a Kickstart that's in stark
contrast in terms of Asian markets to
Japan of course where the Nikkei uh has
recently been hitting a record high
notwithstanding some of the uh downward
movement you just mentioned overnight
um partly on the back of a weekend which
helps it um helps its exports but also
because it's actually been able
ironically to introduce some inflation
which is something that it hasn't been
able to do for several decades
um I wanted to touch on on the inflation
data we've seen over the last week or so
including this morning from France the
difference between Continental Europe
and the UK and I guess paired with the
UK you could put the us too in terms of
uh softer inflation data out of out of
Continental Europe and a bit stronger
here clearly that has implications for
interest rates which can affect
valuations on the stock market but but
it's also happening because of a
slightly weaker economic Outlook so what
stage are we in now I mean does that
mean the UK is now less attractive the
ftse 100 over the next six months
relative to Continental Europe or the
other way around
well I think I think you you make a
valid point obviously the ECB the
European Central Bank has also been
quite aggressive in rising at raising
its own interest rates but by the same
token perhaps the Outlook is a little
cleaner the worry of course is that
raising interest rates in order to choke
demand is something of a blunt chore and
we have concerns on both sides of the
pond than if either the Federal Reserve
or indeed the bank of England should
overshoot on interest rates that could
well push the country into recession
obviously in the UK we've avoided
recession over the last couple of months
by the skin of our teeth and at the
moment the economic data coming through
is relatively resilient so that's
suggesting that there are possibly more
interest rate Rises to come from the
bank of England and we're not quite done
on the high rate hiking cycle yet in
Chile inflation is firmly under control
Richard Hunter thanks so much for
joining us I'm afraid we will have to
leave it there today but uh much
appreciated we're still to come here on
Ian King live record sales for
Bloomsbury as uh readers term to books
in challenging Economic Times I'll be
speaking to the chief executive
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
crisis continues to bite one area doing
well is publishing as the British public
continue to bury their headset in books
this morning the Harry Potter publisher
Bloomsbury posted record sales for last
year and it's fully results the
publisher said sales were up 15 to 264
million pounds for the year to the end
of February profits up 16 31 million
pounds well did I say join me now Nigel
Newton the chief executive of Bloomsbury
uh publishing a very good morning to you
Nigel great great to see you
um as we mentioned there a bit in the
intro I mean 15 up for sale 16 up for
profits despite the the cost of living
crisis or perhaps you could argue sort
of because of it
well we've been very lucky with two uh
bad uh terrible things in the world
helping us first of all in the lockdowns
uh people turn back to books they became
so desperately sick of watching a
streaming series that never ended
um that they turned to these uh funny
things you know first printed in 1452 by
gustenburg but have a beginning a middle
and an end so you know you know where
you stand with a book so that um that
created this 43 growth we've seen since
the start of the pandemic over a couple
of years which has been extraordinary
and it continues but the second thing is
you've just said is the cost of living
crisis and if a paperback book costs
6.99
8.99 it's pretty cheap compared to other
forms of diversion including monthly
subscriptions to streaming services and
other activities so yes we and and other
members of our industry
are continuing to see a boom through the
wonderful bookshops that we Supply
worldwide your growth numbers though I
think it's fair to say have been ahead
of uh the the broad Market if you kind
of classify yourselves uh in that in
that space why do you think you've been
able to exceed that typical growth
well I think
um uh due to a combination of strategy
and luck so the strategy is that we are
unusual in our industry in combining
academic publishing uh with General
publishing so we published 2 300 books a
year and many of them are academic and
so they're aimed at a different Market
they're in particularly at University
libraries
um and so they have their high points of
the year in October back to University
and the financial year-end for
universities of June so they they have
their institutional funding which is the
completely different order to the
consumer Demand on high streets and main
streets and online bookshots where the
big moments of the year or the Christmas
gift buying season and the summer
paperback uh reading Boom season or
ebook downloads go on home holiday so I
think why Bloomsbury has worked
um has been that we are a portfolio of
portfolios and in a in a world in which
you can't really uh predict success we
can only predict what is good and the
rest is in the lack of the publishing
Gods but we've managed like Napoleon's
generals to
pick people uh as our commissioning
editors who are good at picking books
and have fancy of luck and are
passionate Publishers of books they
believe in such as Louise Kennedy's
trespasses which recently became a
bestseller this is a debut novelist
who's shortlisted for the women's prize
about set like Kenneth Brenner's film
Belfast in the height of the troubles in
the 70s in Belfast and the love affair
between a young school teacher and an
older Barrister who defends Ira members
and Nigel I I know you weren't uh you're
being facetious you weren't outright
criticizing the streaming world and the
TV world at the top of the interview but
uh but that you just prefer books which
I totally understand but but there's
also obviously benefits of this huge
amount of money pouring into to TV and
film over the last decade when you own
rights so so do you still get a piece of
this new HBO series that that's coming
on on the Harry Potter books are there
other titles like that where you could
see a kicker to your bottom line by not
by doing nothing but by having been in
in the right place with these rights
uh yeah yes of course and and and you're
right I'm a a great fan of stream
television myself that I was explaining
a social yeah we certainly do benefit so
when the HBO Max uh series that starts
in a few years time once it's uh
progressed
um there there will be multiple episodes
of each of the seven books in the Harry
Potter series and and thus might go on
for a decade and who knows do we have a
financial piece of that no not at all uh
film rights are always reserved
exclusively to the author but the
impacts of films on Book Sales of
successful films and streaming series uh
is enormous and so that is where the
real upside to Bloomsbury shareholders
uh exists there's another one coming
that that is very noteworthy
um which is that we were fortunate to be
approached and asked to buy the great
independent publisher head of Zeus
founded by Anthony Chisholm and run by
his son Nick and in their back post was
a book called A Trilogy for the three
body Problem by the Chinese science
fiction novelist XI Jin Liu which
foresees a a future invasion of the
Earth by extraterrestrial life but
people who like physics like this book
very very much because it's so accurate
in describing hypothetical uh Futures
and this has been bought by Netflix it's
being produced by D.B Weiss and David
benioff who you remember produced Game
of Thrones and it's the biggest as I
understand it invest in Netflix history
um and a trailer is coming out soon it's
been completed filming
um and the series will stream within the
year stimulating the almost million copy
sales that have a Zeus our part of
blooms we have made of the three books
in their first uh decade of publication
so that's another example and a third
and final one is an article appeared
recently saying that William uh
dalrymple's magisterial history of the
East India company called the Anarchy
has been bought up by Bollywood for a
brilliance
uh
streaming series of British uh perfidy
in India that I think is currently
seeking its Financial backers and the
Anarchy is one of the best history books
you've ever read and this new series
will bring a whole new audience to it
Nigel uh we'll have to leave it there
thank you so much for joining us this
morning great to see you
thank you thank you Nigel Newton there
at Bloomsbury
now members of the crisis hit CBI begin
voting on its future today the business
lobbying group has been rocked by
allegations of inappropriate behavior
which led to the cancellation of
membership subscriptions by dozens of
Blue Chip members including the likes of
Aviva and the John Lewis partnership
joining me now is Simon kalasi Aldridge
Chief campaigns director at the CBI
thanks so much for for joining me I I
guess uh we've seen some of the press
the the press releases relating to the
the plan that's being put out uh and of
course then that the process that the
members will vote on it's being titled
there's words in the release of a
renewed CBI to just give us a couple of
the key key points that you think will
convince people that really is renewed
thank you yeah so what we have set out
today is a comprehensive
program of renewed culture renewed
purpose renewed values and this is the
result of the one of the biggest
listening exercises we've ever done uh
with our members with our staff and it
covers culture and what the things that
we need to do to um and the action that
we've taken to renew our culture uh
We've listened to our members on our
purpose uh and actually that was one of
the areas where they you know really
recognized the need to have a strong and
unified voice for business and they want
to see that continuing from us and also
actions that we've taken on our people
so the fox Williams report set out 34
recommendations and what we've set out
today is action that we have taken we
will have by that egm next week have in
progress or completed all for 34 of
those
um and that that is what we've set out
today and I do hope that that is the
comprehensive review into purpose and
culture that people need to see from us
um and this requires approval from from
your members I mean is this a make or
break vote from your members uh the CBI
could could fail to survive if it
doesn't go your way and just talk us
through when we'll get the results
so the egm is on Tuesday next week and
voting is open today and we'll close uh
just after at the egm and we hope to be
able to announce the results that day
what uh in answer to your other question
I think one of the really important
things to recognize is this is a 30-page
document uh but is a comprehensive
product that shows everything that we
have done you know we know that we
needed to act we listened to our people
we listened to our members and the
action that we've taken today and the
action that we will continue to take uh
is setting out all of that all the
products and the result of all of that
hard work this is everything that our
staff have been focusing on over the
last three months we are making
comprehensive governance changes in
terms of how we recruit and who sits on
our board we have a new Chief people
officer and she reports into the board
and one of the things that we found was
that people and culture needed to be a
strategic priority and that is now going
to be the case so you know I hope that
members will be able to see that what we
have done is listening and acting
I mean I I've seen some of those
measures a new Point particularly in the
press release to the new peoples and
culture committee what what powers does
that committee have
so I think from a governance perspective
it's really important to make sure that
a board is able to look at and take
decisions on strategic priorities and in
the past people and culture was not seen
as a strategic priority and we are
changing that we know that that needs to
change and this new board this new
subcommittee of the board will be
looking at our people and our culture
and our processes on an ongoing basis so
we have already taken action as it's
outlined in the prospectus and as I've
some of the which I've talked through
but this isn't just a you know do it
once and never look at it again this is
a journey this is a process and
something that we need to make sure we
keep looking at and keep acting on
and and in terms of uh you know the
importance of of this vote that's one
thing and and the Sky News is Mark
climber reported yesterday that lawyers
are Consulting the possibility of
insolvency
um the other big question is is whether
the funding come comes back or not what
portion of your prior funding has been
lost over the the last six months and
and what's your timeline when does that
need to come back by to ensure the
long-term survival of CBI are you
surviving month to month or is there
Runway to to last for a year
so we any responsible board would be
having those conversations and that is
what that is
um I think we have retained the majority
of our members we did have a few dozen
members uh leave us over the last three
months majority in dollar term in pound
terms as well or just uh in in terms of
plurality of of individuals so I think I
think it is you know making sure that
what we're doing is showing that members
will have the confidence in us again and
I hope that that's what they will do in
in terms of how many members have left
that is dozens of members and you know
some of those are larger firms have you
seen some of those are smaller firms uh
but I think one of the things that's
really important for us is that we
represent businesses of all sizes in
every sector uh in every part of the
country in every nation in every region
um and I am confident that we still do
retain uh the majority of our members
that sit in those different brackets and
and again sorry to leave the point find
a final of going back to it is this vote
a vote for the CBI survival if it goes
against the cbi's proposal over the next
week is that it
so this is a vote in in for it in
confidence so the the the resolution
that's set out in the prospectus is is
to just for members to decide whether
they have confidence in the actions that
we have taken
um the actions that we have taken are
comprehensive I wouldn't underestimate
the amount of work that we have done and
the amount of work that we will continue
to do not only on our purpose and and
why people want to be members of the CBI
in the first place but also on our
people and our culture and our
governance
um so that is what members are voting on
next week they're voting on that
confidence in the action that we've
taken an action that we will continue to
take and yes it is a very important
moment it is very important for us to
make sure that we have can renew that
confidence you know have that renewed
Confidence from our members that is
incredibly important but it is a journey
Simon thanks so much for joining us
really appreciate it uh uh on this busy
day and week for the CBI well uh next up
was the Business Review to discuss the
the main newspaper stories I want to get
straight into bringing uh bringing our
guest uh rather than going through some
of the stories the business editor at
the Daily Mail and then on Sunday route
Sutherland Ruth there but before I know
we were going to dive through some set
stories that we picked out but I thought
I actually just get your reaction on the
CBI uh interview if I may and uh and I
guess the the the way that the business
Community is is looking at this next
week or so and indeed whether it is a
critical one for the long-term survival
of the CBR
I think it's absolutely critical for the
long-term survival of the CBI I mean you
can't underestimate the importance of
this the CBI is the flagship British
business body representing us not just
here but also abroad so it's clearly
Paramount importance that they are
absolutely a beacon for all the things
that they say that they want business to
stand for
um in terms of being a safe place for
for women to work and in terms of being
of women being able to pursue
um careers without harassment or or
other issues of that sort um so I think
it absolutely is
um existential I think you've seen some
of the big businesses pulling away and
reconsidering their commitment to the
CBI and I think the honest is on them to
prove that they really have set the
right track
um looking ahead
and how hard a task have they got I mean
even if this vote goes their way and
their members sort of give them that
vote of confidence at least in the short
term how tough a job have they got to
successfully Rebrand and and relaunch
their image in the eyes of both the
wider public and most importantly the
paying business community
I think it is quite tough isn't it
because think of it this way if you're a
female chief executive and you're paying
subscriptions to the CBI out of your
shareholders money that's quite the
thing to think about there isn't it
um and also it's not as if the CBI is
the only option so you've got other
business bodies you've got the British
Chambers of Commerce you've got
manufacturing organizations like make UK
that specialize in certain areas so I
think the issue really is can this can
the CBI should the CBI survive in its
current form perhaps is there a better
way I mean even before all of this
happened I would have said that the CBI
was looking a little bit that's outmoded
you know it's quite it's been around
since the 60s it was born out of an era
when most employers were big
manufacturing employers and you know it
was the voice of the employer against or
in discussion with the Trade union
movement in a very different world so I
think even leaving aside the current
issues in know you still had question
marks around the CBI and its role
um so I think it's it's good in a way
you know let's hope that good comes out
of this in terms of questioning whether
this really is the right way to
represent British business and let's
face it representing British business
could not be more important than it is
right now you know when you've got a
cost of living crisis you've got a very
high pay for certain Chief Executives
and you've got a lot of people still
feeling that there's a trust gap between
business between employers look at all
the industrial relations problems at the
moment so you know I think the the fact
that business I believe can be a force
for good I think that needs proper
really strong representation in the UK
but also in the wider world as we're
looking towards brexit Prosperity Ruth
thanks so much for joining us today
really really appreciate it and
apologies we didn't get to those
individual uh stories that we'd
discussed ahead of time right so
live the plant-based Burger Company
setting its sites on the us we'll be
right back
[Music]
um tell me how you survive a crisis
you prepare
not necessarily for the specific because
some crises come out of the blue sky but
you make yourself as resilient as
possible and that's true if you're an
individual or an organization or
government itself and you get into real
trouble when you haven't made sensible
precautions I think of a crisis as being
poised
between on the one hand emergencies that
we've practiced prepared for the
Emergency Services and on the other hand
disaster
and what makes the difference what tips
it over is preparation think about some
of the things which might happen
probably they won't but if they did
it would be very serious let me solve
this is is your apartment or your house
if it catches fire
take out insurance
do you have a set of keys
or would you discover that you're locked
out
your best best apparel to appear on Sky
News is inside the taxis outside time is
ticking by
don't get yourself into that sort of
crisis situation and those are trivial
examples but it's the little things
attention to detail and I use the word
anticipation because what it it means is
you conjure up a real picture in your
mind
a feeling of what it would be like if it
happened they come in two forms there's
the Sudden Impact crisis that you can't
really foresee when it will happen and
you just have to make do with the best
you can if you prepared but the really
dangerous ones are the Slow Burn crises
year on year the situation worsens but
nobody quite likes to tackle it or it's
thought to be too expensive or
governments just simply prefer to ignore
it
[Music]
enough
foreign
[Music]
substitute Market continues to grow in
one company that's expanding its Global
reach is neat Burger which has just
raised 18 million dollars as it sets its
sights on the US I'm joined now by the
chief executive Zach Bishop Zach great
to see you so so just talk us through
why your burger uh is different from
some of the options that are also out
there already well I think we're focused
on the experiential side of it I think
very often what you're seeing is some of
these big cpg businesses go straight to
Market without kind of any thought for
the consumer experience everyone's kind
of having their first time so to speak
when you come to us we've ensured we've
curated that experience and I think it's
one of our superpowers is our proximity
to the consumer we listen we adapt and
we make sure that they have the
experience and quality they want and how
big a challenge do you see it eventually
in the US market I mean clearly there's
been a lot of competition you're no
longer the first mover you know beyond
meat and the likes have been there for a
couple years yeah of course but we're
doing this in a different approach we'll
talk targeting first and foremost from
the consumer side we've got brick and
mortar stores where people can really
see and feel the brand and taste it
first hand and in terms of where we are
in the cycle for people potentially
switching from real meat to to
Alternative meat I mean if you looked at
the beyond meat share price you'd say
this this trend peaked a couple of years
ago yeah I I don't like it when people
say this is a fad or it's going away
fundamentally we're talking about a huge
cultural shift in how people eat and
there's bound to be bumps along the way
um I think the data doesn't lie year on
year there is growth in the space the
demand is not going that way we see this
internally in our own metrics and sales
and I see this externally with every
other data point and I think there'll be
two things that drive this um number one
is the product and the quality of the
products and number two is price point
and I think if you look
um every one of those is improving
quality whether it's texture and flavor
we're seeing great great improvements
and then the final price point there's
been so much investment that you're
seeing the price come down Zach thanks
so much for joining us so we had to cut
it to cut it good luck with the US
launch that does it for Ian King live uh
Kimberly Leonard's next